good afternoon and welcome to the
columbia world leaders forum it's my
pleasure to welcome our distinguished
guests today judge song hun seong
president of the International Criminal
Court I want to recognize first of all
the institute for the study of human
rights the co-sponsor of this event and
the institute's faculty members who have
worked so hard to give us the
opportunity to hear from president song
and have this discussion today with a
very special opportunity for us a
professor Eleazar Barkin is of course
the director and would be here but for
illness yasmin argus an adjunct
professor of international law and
international human rights law at sepa
and the associate director of the
institute for the study of human rights
and who will fill in to moderate matthew
Heaphy and john Washburn two of the
institute's research scholars who
specialize in studying the ICC very
important that all of you have helped to
bring this about the International
Criminal Court or the ICC was founded on
the principle that the world's nations
are members of a single global community
and have a shared interest in
establishing international rules
protecting our most basic human rights
the ICC commenced its work on July first
2002 its first conviction in 2012 was of
Congolese rebel commander thomas lubanga
who was sentenced to 14 years in prison
for a campaign of violence against
Congolese villages and for the
conscription of child soldiers
the ICC's mission grounded in a claim of
universal jurisdiction over particularly
egregious crimes possesses several
fundamental challenges the most
significant of these is a familiar one
the inherent tension of enforcing
international law in a world of
sovereign nations and governments there
is also the ICC's need two more firmly
establish its authority by building a
record of effective prosecutions and the
courts complicated and still evolving
relationship with the United States
president song who is from South Korea
and became the ICC's president in 2009
has assumed a set of responsibilities in
a position that are not for the timid
for the faint of heart the difficulties
facing the ICC and also the great
promise the court holds for global
society are made manifest by the current
situation in Kenya the ICC has charged
for individuals for crimes against
humanity committed in connection with
national elections held there in
December 2007 a chaotic and terribly
violent episode in which more than 1,000
Kenyans lost their lives and over
600,000 were displaced from their homes
two of the individuals charged last
month by the ICC are aroo-whoo Kenyatta
currently a candidate for the Kenyan
presidency and his running mate William
Ruto Kenya's Election Commission as
cleared Kenyatta and ruto to remain on
the ballot for the March 4th national
elections notwithstanding the ICC's
decision to move forward with
prosecutions Kenyatta is one of two top
presidential contenders and not in
significantly the son of Kenya's
founding father and first president when
I traveled to Nairobi last month to
celebrate the opening of the Columbia
global center there
one could see and feel firsthand the
passion and the energy that the Kenyan
people are devoting to building a
political system that aspires to be a
model of democratic participation at
every level of government their ambition
is large if not yet fully realized how
will Kenyan voters respond to this
highly unusual electoral scenario will
they be moved by a desire to acknowledge
an international judicial process beyond
their borders dedicating to dispensing
justice for crimes still fresh in the
consciousness of Kenyan society or will
the ICC charges provoke a backlash of
national pride and rejection of external
authority working to the advantage of
those charged events in Kenya also
exposed the conflicted posture of the
United States with respect to the ICC in
a recent YouTube video message that he
begins and ends in Swahili President
Obama uses his personal connection to
the nation to encourage Kenyans to
reject violence and intimidation and to
hold free and fair elections the pending
ICC charges and the isolation of Kenya
that could be an outcome of a
presidential election are referenced
only implicitly nor is there any
acknowledgement of the fact that while
the u.s. supports the ICC's mission and
principles the united states has
declined to ratify the ICC treaty and
therefore is not a member the ICC's
intervention in Kenyan affairs may be
particularly dramatic but the larger
issues raised there are by no means
unique to date 121 countries have agreed
to be ICC members according to the rome
statute which created the ICC the
court's jurisdiction exists only after a
determination that a criminal suspects
home nation is clearly unwilling or
unable to carry out its own fair
investigation or prosecution by design
the ICC is obligated to walk a very fine
line there for
seeing the interests of justice with
respect for national sovereignty
president song confronts these competing
interests on a daily basis and he has
been unwavering in developing the ICC
into an institution that can fulfill its
mission of critical importance to global
society in 2010 un secretary-general ban
ki-moon said of the ICC quote there is
no going back in this age of
accountability those who commit the
worst human crimes will be held
responsible I know that our guest today
wholeheartedly agrees with that view
please join me in welcoming judge song
president of the International Criminal
Court
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
thank the columbia university institute
for the study of human rights in
American NGO Coalition for the
International Criminal Court for
inviting me to speak today and for the
excellent work they do here in the
United States and beyond actually uh
since present Bollinger gave you the
full explanation about the all the
basics of the ICC I have very little to
tell you but it's very good to be back
in New York this is a city that after
Seoul and the hague most feels like home
to me of course here at Columbia I may
be venturing into enemy territory since
my heart still resides with NYU where I
thought in the 1990s I am extremely glad
to be at Columbia though it is a happy
coincidence that i am giving this speech
in the italian academy up on Amsterdam
Avenue given that the International
Criminal Court owes its founding treaty
the Rome Statute to Italy and has its
home in the Netherlands
I want to talk about the International
Criminal Court today which I am very
proud to serve as a as an appeals judge
and president though you no doubt you
will have seen from the title my topic
extends to an issue that is far broader
than the ISIS itself the fight against
impunity for atrocity crimes the ICC is
very much at the forefront of this fight
not alone but rather as an central
element in a broad global system that
brings together international
organizations including the United
Nations States and civil society to help
address the worst international crimes I
want to start by giving you a historical
background to this struggle before going
on to discuss the ways in which the ISIS
is working today to end the impunity for
international crimes I will then discuss
the architecture of the evolving
international criminal justice system
addressing some of his strengths as well
as some of the challenges that have
emerged allow me to begin however by
going back in time to share some of my
own background with you 63 years ago an
armed conflict broke out in my home
country Korea
I was nine year old boy at that time for
three months during the battle fought
for seoul city my family had to hide in
a in a hot and humid underground bunker
it was my task to emerge above ground
every day to find food and bring it back
to the bunker to do this the
nine-year-old had to walk 16 kilometers
every day many times when warplanes
appear in the sky and started dropping
bombs on the city I had to run for cover
dropping all the groceries i had just
collected during daily trips to find
food I past hundreds of dead bodies
lying on the street to this day I can
precisely remember the horrible stench
of the decomposing corpse in those hot
summer days I may have been too young to
be mobilized but I was old enough to
realize the immense suffering and
destruction that war inflicts thankfully
the war ended and I was able to grow up
in relative peace and prosperity a
privilege that I have always been
profoundly grateful for regrettably
there are still far too many parts of
the world today in which piece remains
an unattainable luxury
as president of the ICC I have met with
victims in Uganda and the Democratic
Republic of the Congo in two years ago
some were former child soldiers
grappling to rebuild their lives other
victims who were missing arms or legs or
lips or years which had been
intentionally cut off the brutality
which they suffered reminded me that
unfortunately with so many countries
caught up in conflict we are far from
eradicated the depravity and mass
violence those of us who are granted the
blessing of peace and safety from this
horrific violence must always ask
ourselves what we can do with this gift
I chose a legal career and I have
believed all my life that it is through
law that the worst violence and cruelty
inflicted upon humans can be prevented
this is the same belief that has guided
the development of international
criminal justice through the 20th
century in the aftermath of the Second
World War there was a fundamental
overhaul of international structures
aimed at preventing the recurrence of
the appalling violence of the war the
United Nations and the International
Court of Justice were founded to enable
peaceful cooperation and
settlement of disputes between states
the international military tribunals in
Nuremberg and Tokyo were created to try
the architects of the shocking
atrocities committed by Nazi Germany and
its allies regrettably while the seas of
the International Criminal Justice were
planted in Nuremberg the ensuing Cold
War rival II push this whole idea into
the background it took decades before
new life was breathe it's into the
project of international criminal
justice to ad hoc tribunals were
established in the first half of the
1990s to bring accountability and
justice for the heinous crimes committed
in the former Yugoslavia and Rwanda the
period was a period also saw a dramatic
renewal of the campaign by diplomats
lawyers and civil society to end
impunity for the atrocity crimes
wherever in the world they take place
these aspirations came into fruition in
July 1998 when delegates from 160
countries gathered in Rome to negotiate
an international treaty that was both
the statute for a new permanent
International Criminal Court and also a
powerful statement of intent by the
international community that impunity
for atrocity crimes would no longer
he tolerated in a far shorter time than
anyone expected the necessary 60
ratifications were achieved and on July
the first two thousand to the Rome
Statute entered into force the ICC was
born as a new independent international
organisation mandated to investigate and
prosecute genocide crimes against
humanity war crimes and potentially
after 2017 the crime of aggression today
more than 10 years in operation the ICC
is a C's of situations in eight
countries democratic republic of the
congo uganda Central African Republic
Sudan Kenya Libya the Ivory Coast and
most recently Molly all but the latest
latest investigation have already given
rise to cases and prosecutions before
the ICC the prosecutor is furthermore
conducting preliminary examinations of
alleged crimes in Afghanistan Colombia
Georgia Guinea Honduras korea and
nigeria two trials have been completed
with the judgments issued the first one
was a conviction in a case regarding
child soldiers in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and second was an
acquittal both are currently and their
appeal
as is the first decision regarding
reparations for the victims of crimes it
is now clear that the court is at the
heart of a global movement that demands
an end to impunity for the most
atrocious crimes this movement extends
far beyond the seat of the court in the
Netherlands the United Nations is the
other major actor in this movement to
end impunity there is a common
misconception of the ICC that it is a
part of the UN while the two are close
in many respects the ICC is an entirely
independent institution delegates in
Rome in 1998 recognized that peace and
justice were interlinked and they
constructed a relationship between the
two institutions that was aimed to be
mutually reinforcing such that both
peace and justice could be achieved the
United Nations Security Council as the
preeminent body charged with the
maintenance of international peace and
security is the primary forum through
which this UN ICC relationship is played
out the Security Council has the ability
to refer situations to the prosecutor of
the ICC and has done so twice in the
cases of Darfur Sudan and Libya in the
situation of Libya the council voted
unanimously
mostly with 15 positive votes including
by the United States Russian Federation
China and India however just as the
Security Council has the power to expand
the jurisdiction of the ICC it can also
limit it the rome statute gives the
Security Council the power to suspend an
ICC case for a renewable 12-month period
should the council believe that it was
necessary for the sake of international
peace and security this has never
happened in the history of the court so
far while the 22 referrals of situations
by the Security Council have been
considered at the time as high points
for the ICC they expose clearly some of
the very real challenges inherent in the
relationship between the UN and the ICC
by adopting the rome statute states
established not just the court but an
entire system of international criminal
justice it's been said accurately that
the architecture of the system splits a
responsibilities we're by the ICC
carries out judicial work but the
enforcement is devolved to two states
therefore the ICC will investigate
prosecute prosecute and try suspects of
primes but for arrest warrants to be
implemented or evidence to be provided
or witnesses to be protected or
relocated and sentences to be enforced
States must assist the ICC however the
need for cooperation goes far beyond
these technical issues to the political
support that the ICC requires this is
evident nowhere more than with the
referrals of situation by the Security
Council when it comes to the fore none
of the Sudanese government officials
have so far faced the allegations
against them in the Libya situation
suspects are likewise yet to be
transferred to the Hague and last summer
a delegation of the ICC staff were
arrested and detained for a month in
Libya while on an official mission
unfortunately the Security Council has
not provided the ICC the help it needs
to discharge the mandate given to it in
Council resolutions for the system
established by States to truly function
we need a far more consistent and
vigilant approach by the Security
Council there is also a financial
question that requires attention the
rome statute and the relationship
agreement between the ICC and the UN
anticipate that the UN shall help fund
the costly investigations and
prosecutions arising from UN Security
Council referrals of the situation's to
the court
yet in both the Sudan and Libya
resolutions a provision was added
prohibiting UN funds from helping the
ICC this has meant that the states
parties to the Rome Statute have so far
picked up the bill for the work done by
the ICC stemming from a security council
decision adopted on behalf of the entire
world community in order to preserve
peace and security this conflict will
need to be addressed in the near future
and I cannot see it resolved easily
without a constructive approach by all
countries on the Security Council of
course including the United States while
the ICC and the UN together maybeee the
most visible leaders of the fight to end
impunity it is ultimately state whose
action or inaction will determine the
success of this quest the ICC unlike its
predecessor tribunals for Rwanda and the
former Yugoslavia has been this desert
designed as a court of last resort the
legal foundation upon which it rests the
rome statute requires that the ICC only
step in if a state is unwilling or
unable genuinely to prosecute the crimes
in question this has a number of
powerful implications
firstly it means that every state
joining the Rome Statute can be
confident that they retain the primary
jurisdiction to conduct proceedings for
any crimes covered under the rome
statute whether genocide the crimes
against humanity or war crimes I cannot
stress enough that this is both the
right and the responsibility of each
state ultimately the fight against
impunity can only succeed when the
national justice system of each state is
strong enough to stand against the
atrocity crimes this notion has recently
attracted a lot of attention in the
Assembly of States Parties and there is
increasing awareness of the need to
involve development agencies in helping
the strengthening of national justice
systems I am particularly glad that the
United Nations increasingly taking a
strong role in this area since the UN is
simply uniquely placed to advance the
rule of law in all parts of the world
where international assistance is needed
this shows how the real power of the ICC
is not in the court alone but in in an
entire system of international justice
incorporating international
organizations states and civil society
organisations with every year that goes
by the normative consensus
rose stronger that justice must be done
in the case of mass atrocities by
helping the entrenchment of strong legal
and societal norms that prohibit massive
crimes and human right abuses the Rome
Statute can help us move forward move
toward a safer world in which people
around the globe can live and prosper in
peace this is not a task for justice
sector lon it is a goal that can only be
achieved with the simultaneous
strengthening of democracy development
and the rule of law ladies and gentlemen
since we are at the world leaders forum
let me finish by offering some personal
reflections on what it means to lead an
institution like the International
Criminal Court first of all as president
of an organization with a over 90
nationalities represented in a staff of
over 700 I have developed an extremely
high level of respect for diversity and
cultural difference my time at the ICC
has shown me that to lead is to be alone
in the eye of a storm I am surrounded by
very gifted and hard-working
professionals and I could not do my job
without them but ultimately
I am the one who carries the
responsibility for the decisions that I
take taking the responsibility means
that i also have to be ready to face
criticism fortunately i have been
blessed with unlimited asian patience I
have learned to deal calmly with the all
kinds of obstacles while ensuring that
things get done leading a judicial
institution creates certain very
specific challenges as a court the ISIS
is not a hierarchical institution first
of all every judge is independent and
his or her own boss as president I am
Primus inter Paris the first among
equals furthermore the ISIS is a
structure includes a prosecutor who is
likewise independent while I coordinated
with the with the prosecutor on issues
of a court wide significance but she's
both of her own office then we have a
registrar who works under my authority
providing services to the judiciary as
well as the prosecutor's office solving
problems within this complex governance
arrangement is not an easy
finally while I represent the
International Criminal Court as its
president I'm also a practicing judge in
the appeals chamber with cases before me
as such I continue continuously have to
safeguard my independence and my
integrity and this has an impact on the
way I live for example the only hobby I
have is to play golf perhaps on a on the
very rare occasions when I have the time
for it but I always play alone since I
do not want to create the impression
that i'm partial to anyone in the same
way the ICC cannot function unless it
retains its independence and its
integrity while we operate in a world in
which political considerations often
rule the ICC must stand apart stand
apart as a non-political judicial
institution this is not easy but I am
convinced that it is the only way in
which the ICC can truly fulfill the role
it has been assigned in the mission to
end impunity for atrocity crimes thank
you very much
you
sorry yes
hi I'm cedras ad and I'm a human rights
and a student here at Columbia my
question for you is I was recently in
Kenya for a few weeks and everyone that
I spoke to whether or not they supported
Kenyatta Andrew to ruto they either did
not support the eye sees the other did
not support the ICC investigation or
they were didn't have much faith in it
so my question to you is how is the ICC
going to continue its investigation and
prosecution in Kenya when there seems to
be such little local cooperation and
support for what you're doing the ICC
set the the opening date starting date
of the Kenya trials there are two Kenya
cases for the one case it was April the
10th and for the second case it it's
going to be it the 11th of April since
there are so many variables here we we
don't know what's going to happen even
just there's no tomorrow to the Kenya
cases or our prosecutors activities in
Kenya and so on but we we will continue
and conduct our tradition work on the
Kenya cases as originally scheduled
regardless of the what's going to happen
in Kenya politically and otherwise their
political process should not affect the
tradition work of the ICC
at the moment I must admit that for
example the logistics aspects of the
Kenya case for example it is not
necessarily easy because these four
suspects are under the summons to appear
they were not arrested people so how and
there they kept on saying they will
comply with the the ICC procedures and
so on so forth so how they will come all
the way to the Hague to attend the trial
and helpful how long and you know and
how the host government will you know
treat them in what way all these
questions are quite not easy we
constantly consult the host government
on these and other issues but you see my
message is that the political domestic
political process that's taking place in
in Kenya should not affect our
traditional schedule or judicial work
yes would you please come to the
microphone
good afternoon thank you very much for
coming to speak to us today my name is
Marilyn Rob I'm a senior in columbia
college studying philosophy and American
Studies and my question for you has to
do with the tension you spoke of about
how to have international standards in a
world of sovereign nations and
specifically I'm interested in you spoke
of how it's hard for the ICC to have as
much power as it could when nations that
are powerful in the UN aren't members of
the ICC and so I'm interested in how you
see the future of the relationship
between the ICC and countries like the
United States that are not currently
members when I first arrived in The
Hague in early two thousand three for
some initial period all these eighteen
judges were not at all sure whether this
new creature called the ICC would be
able to survive the hostilities shown by
the big powers for example by the Bush
administration and so on ten years later
however I am happy to tell you we have
grown to be a fully functioning
international judicial institution and
all these statistics and numbers are
telling you how how much progress the
ICC has successfully made so far the
these big powers this is a one aspects
of the ICC work I should continue to at
all address and work on
the this big countries have its own
reasons why they are reluctant to ratify
the Rome Statute for example it it was
said that you know there was an
effective checking mechanism against
possible abuse of the ICC prosecutors
strong rather strong power you know or
the the fact that the Rome Statute
allowed the Security Council to refer
the certain country situation to us will
inevitably sort of influence the this
judicial institution politically
unnecessary politically or some each
country has their own reasons that I
could I could argue that's not that you
know that shouldn't be interpreted that
way I have my own argument but talking
of the United States the ICC and the
Obama administration in particular have
been enjoying rather close cooperation
on the matters of mutual concern it it
ranges from simple intelligence sharing
down to the US government's dispatch of
100 military advisers 20 ganda with the
hope
you know helping or ganda arrest Joseph
Kony and other l/r are a you know people
and then recent legislation that include
the ICC in in the legislative scheme
that the one who will provide an
information which will lead to the
arrest of this ICC the fugitives from
the ICC justice will be rewarded with
certain cash or other benefit all these
things powerfully indicate that US
government has been quite fully
cooperating with the ICC having said
that but we have to face a domestic
political reality in this country in
order to get the Rome Statute ratified
by the US government you go out and have
to persuade at least the two-thirds of
the US senators it's a 67 or 68 US
senators as that's that's not easy
so it will take some time but you know
since it as far as the area of
international criminal justice and human
rights and democracy and rule of law are
concerned us has been the champion in
this area and it's very clear ICC and
the USA share these missions goals and
values so although it may take many more
years I I hope and I believe the US will
someday be a member of this ICC family
thank you very much for that encouraging
answer that is you try to take somebody
from this side yes please in the back
could you come to the front hello I'm so
entire reporter from Columbia spectator
I have a question that sometimes the
actions of international organizations
led like you are considered intervention
of internal affairs like or expression
of national interest and sometimes
enforcing value systems so how would you
balance the international justice and
respect for country's internal policy
and also do you think what ICC is doing
is a representation of sort of universal
morals thank you well the unlike the ad
hoc tribunals like International
Tribunal for the former Yugoslavia or
Rhonda as I said in my speech the the
complementarity principle prevails in
this
international criminal justice system
where the ICC take has taken the center
stage that means it is primarily
responsibilities of each state party to
conduct necessary genuine investigation
and prosecution of the crimes I mean
this I cece rome statute crimes in the
domestic setting as i said only if a
state is not able maybe a whole system
is just a broken down or whatever
reasons if the state is not able or
willing to do so only then can the ICC
step in so Isis a is always there at
least as a safety net and closely
watching what you guys are doing in your
own country you know regarding the
judiciary operation so I think this is a
very good solution
you know it's a the as i said i repeat
this primarily the responsibility of is
a each state to do the job and i cc-can
only step in if that particular country
is not able or willing to do the job
properly so i think this this is called
the principle of complementarity so here
in this context one of the most
important thing is how to strengthen the
national judicial capacity of each state
you see a country like the US has a
fully functioning judicial and
prosecution and play system in place so
no worry about that but in many
countries don't necessarily have
well-functioning our judiciary then what
should we do you see the doll Isis is
not a development aid agency or a
training academy but we always try to
find some other institutions or that
that have the experience and expertise
and capacity which can help strengthen
the judicial capacity national capacity
of other other countries so we've been
in certain cases that the isis has been
a successful matchmaker and this regard
so the is important too
to you know strengthen the national
capacity for two in order in the treaty
to of in order for this particular
principle to function as they should
thank you we have time for one and a
half questions so yes in the back hi
thank you for can you hear me yeah hi
thank you for coming here my name is
Chris Kyle Jenna some JD PhD student
with Department political science and I
have the following question on the legal
side some of the most interesting things
that have come from the ICC are some
spirited the sense for example Justice
has several where where he descends with
the appeal with the Apollo chamber
findings but also what certain legal
commentators have said as a general
tendency of the court to move away from
the jurisprudence of prior tribunals is
the ICTY so my question towards you is
can you describe a little bit what goes
on in the life of a judge when you
deliberate and how it feels to be there
in in the actual making of the law in
the Apollo chamber yeah d that's very
interesting question you see the rome
statute requires that at least one-third
of the 18 judges should be woman but the
past elections amply showed that you
know more than one-third of the judges a
woman you see the at the moment out of
18 judges 11-hour woman and seven are
men so a male judge like mere might soon
be an endangered species
so this gender competition may have some
bearing on the you know development of
the our jurisprudence that's one point
and the in the judiciary in the bench
there is no American judge because
you're not a state party therefore our
jurisprudence hasn't been influenced by
american legal thinking or american
practice or american procedure one
example would be witness proofing we
after much debate among the judges we we
just we don't want to you know just we
cannot accept that kind of american
practice for instance so this in this
particular sense our the development of
our traditional proceeding proceeding
may already be different from that of
the ad hoc tribunals there are many
reasons to make all this difference
because the ad hoc tribunals do have a
primacy two distinction on primacy over
the national
jurisdictions and in those affected
areas but with us as I said I you see
the we don't have a choice fictional
primacy as I said it's primarily it's a
responsibilities of each state to to
investigate and prosecute all this ICC
crimes so even for that reason alone the
development of the jurisprudence might
have to diverge when we sit around and
debate and deliberate on the case of
course the legal offices and others you
know just the right the research paper
citing and the cases of the European
human right court or adult tribunals
proceedings and so on sometimes we we
just borrow or rely on their logics and
theories but I would generally say that
we have stronger desire to develop our
own jurisprudence do you agree daily
here's the my former legal officer who
has been working for me for the last
eight years you agree more less more or
less
I'm actually afraid that we're going to
have to end it here I want to thank you
so much
you